so with the film my big break you you
say it's something that you'll speak
behind for basically eternity I mean you
you believe in this and you feel it's a
tool to help other actors other people
even musicians whatever because it shows
some very real things that aren't really
talked about about fame about success
and what can happen sometimes when stuff
that was there goes away yeah I mean
it's such a personal moving to me that
it's always going to be a part of my
life from here on out until I die and I
hope after I'm gone that this movie
continues to be seen and I think by that
time I'm sure I'm hoping that it will
become its own thing because I think it
is important for people to see what it's
really like here that it's not
necessarily all that glamorous you know
that's not Entertainment Tonight it's
not extra you know where everything is
so perfect in Hollywood and has its
moments don't get me wrong but there's a
lot of blood sweat and tears that people
don't see and what it takes to be in
this town and to put up with this town
because it's a machine I think it's
gonna be an important tool for actors
filmmakers if you're thinking about
getting into acting you know watch this
movie even ask yourself the same
question so and if you're in the
business it kind of helps gives you a
voice I think it was nothing when I came
here to Los Angeles you know this is how
it's gonna be so I think it's an
important movie and I would have liked
to have seen something like this however
I don't think it would have to change
the way I handle things
still would have been like oh that's not
gonna happen to me or I won't make those
those decisions that they made in the
movie you know I would never turn down
TV or any of these things but at the
time and you just don't know how you're
gonna handle it so I think it's
important on many levels how is it for
you to watch the film 10 whatever years
later does it what does it do to you
Ennis I like it you know I don't get
emotional when I see it anymore
necessarily I did when Tommy first
started showing me the movie you know I
remember seeing and then just like
feeling that that heavy yeah you know
I'm like Tony man like me son of a
like why did you do this
and I got very emotional seeing me
because we live a lot of the moments and
you see the ups and the downs
and it puts that nauseousness into your
stomach they I think you feel when
you're pursuing a career here you get
that nauseated to feel like hey like oh
my god and now I kind of have a
perspective on it when I see it you know
I'm able to separate myself and I watch
it through me but I watch it to other
people's eyes you know I wanted to you
guys i watch it to fans i watch it a
girl that I went to school with just
wrote me a Facebook message and said she
came across to watched it she had no
idea you know so it's it's cool I kind
of watch it through the buddy else in
their expense
so what have other actors said when they
see it not maybe just people that are
fans but other actors has it as to
shaking them up or what
what is it done to them so Amy shook me
up to see it um I think a lot of actors
I have yet for my close friends to see
this they're a little bit scared to
watch you have one buddy who's like I
don't know if I can watch this movie he
wants to see it but it's so um it's so
true to what we go through so it's a
little
I think scary to watch there have been
actors that become the screenings or two
different festivals and said that after
seeing this movie they're like done they
don't want to pursue the acting career
anymore this kind of was like the final
you know nail in the coffin for them and
other actors that have seen it and been
inspired by it so it's it's kind of a
cautionary tale and an inspiring movie
at the same time so you know it's making
the rounds people know I are getting and
actors especially a lot of actors that
had just come here better interested
well that was my next question too
because you came here what 18 or 19 uh
yeah it was 19:16 and I know I came here
when I was about 18 as well by myself
and I know we talked about in here out
probably now we wouldn't do that but but
being that age you just feel invincible
what would you tell someone that's 18
maybe doesn't go to college and and
coming here what was what's your advice
without talking them out of being in the
industry because if that's their dream
that's great yeah I say follow your
dreams no matter what whether it be an
actor or whatever you wanted to be an
astronaut but follow your dreams and
never give up ever that's who you are
you can't ever give up but I it has to
be who you are also at the same time it
has to be in you because if it's not
this town will chew you up and spit you
out it does anyway so I would say you
have to be a hundred percent sure that
you're in for this or 110 percent
because you know it's it's not gonna
happen I don't think if it's you're not
in it you know and there are accidents I
mean people get into it and you know how
to make everyone has a different path
but if you're serious about it then you
know by all means follow your dreams but
if you're doing it just to be famous or
you think it'd be fun or it's easy it's
it's not so be sure how would someone
keep themselves intact because it is
easy to fall prey to alcohol or whatever
just numb you know those bad feelings
about yourself or whatever so how would
you advise people to keep themselves
attacked like
it's tough to do and then it's tough to
do in this town I mean everyone goes to
their little party stage I think here in
Los Angeles everyone goes through a
period I didn't go to college so my
college days were essentially a Maslin
that was you know it was the best time
of my life well beyond that I think you
have to keep things in check and
surround yourself with friends who are
gonna put you in check and keep you in
check just surround yourself with good
people and you know don't let things get
to your head you know I think
surrounding yourself with a good people
or keeping your family close to you is
important any books you can I don't know
yeah